عايزه ابدا معكم بحاجه مهمه اتعلمتها في
سكه حياتي
النجاح لا يعرف صدفه ولا حظ ولا وصفه
الوسع ممكن تحط لنا اول السكه تاثر
ممكن اقول لفلان والنبي ابني يشغله
هيطلع خايف مش
ما فيش حد بيحط حد على حيله طب هيشتغل في
الحكومه وماله يشتغل في الحكومه ما يتكا
بس مش هينجح لانه دايما اللي عايز ينجح
بيدور على منورين الاسكيا المصرين ده
الدرس اللي اتعلمته في حياتي لما بشوف ناس
كتيره بتقول لك ايه انا حظي وحش اصل انا
ما عنديش وصفه
اصل مش عارفه طريقه التفكير دي هي لا تكون
الا للفشل
لانه الحظ والصدفه والوصفه
قدام الباب بس لا يمكن يخلينا نكمل
طيب
الفشل
سهل ومريح جدا ما فيش اجمل من اننا
نقول ما لناش دعوه
انا مش طرف
انا ما ليش علاقه ما فيش اجمل من كده لكن
مؤمن جدا الفشل المريح جدا لكن يجيب تيبس
عضلات زي اللي قاعد كده 24 ساعه ما فيش
حاجه بعد شويه لازم علشان يحاول يمشي لازم
يعملوا له علاج طبيعي جدا بالمناسبه انما
اي مسؤوليه وانا مش طرف وانا ضحيه وانا
لسه منها الدنيا ولا حد بيولدني وكتاب
حياتي يا عيني وبعدين نسمع تامر حسني
ونقطع ت ولا تامر عاشور تامر عاشور ونقطع
شرايين يعني مفيش اجمل من
كده ان الواحد
في اي قال الظ
روف كانت مريح الفشل فعلا مريح وانا عايزه
اقول
لكم
ظروف
انا
دي شمال الجيزه ايام ما كنت فيها طفله كنت
بمشي حوالي كيلو على رجلي من بيتنا
للمدرسه في ارض زراعه
البنات معاه اغلبهم من وهم مجهوله او
ثانيه اعدادي بيتخطبوا
وانا بابايا لمدرس ومصر اننا نكمل لحد
الجامعه ليه يا عم لطفي العيال كلها لابسه
دبل
مزيف
وطبعا الورق دلوقتي المدينه
المهندسين بالمناسبه يعني شارع سوريا
[موسيقى]
باستثناء الحته النظيفه بتاعه شارع تبقوا
عارفين خريطه مصر
[موسيقى]
انا عندي كم سنه ماشي طيب كيف بقى
ادخل
في الحياه فتعلمت حاجه مهمه جدا
ان ربنا الفشل مريح جدا لكن النجاح ممتع
جدا جدا جدا عارفين المشهد الشهير بتاع
الطريق الى هناك لما دخلوا مصر بعد ما
عملوا عارفين اللي بيتعمل عليه الكوميكس
ده انا كل نجاح
في حنان عايزه اعمل زيهم
النجاح ممتع في نشوى
بيزغزغ القلب احلى من الايس كريم
بس عشان نوصل للنجاح لازم نبقى عارفين انه
الاول نقرا نفسنا
احتياجات الانسانيه على فكره الناس كتير
جدا بتقف عند المستوى الاول
بيقول انسانيه اساسيه الاكل والشرب والجنس
على فكره زينا زي كل الكائنات الحيه على
وجه الكره الارضيه زي الحيوانات والنباتات
والطيور والاسماك احتياجات الانسانيه او
احتياجات بيولوجيه احتياجات الكائنات عشان
كده في ناس كتيره قوي تقول لك هنا تمام
انا باكل وبشرب وكمان او لما تتجوز راجل
يكفيكي بيعتلك وبيشربك يا حبيبتي انا مش
بطه بتزبط على فكره يعني في عندي احتياجات
انس عن احتياجات البصمه
بتقعد في اول درجه من
درجات
هي الاحتياجات اللي بنتفق احنا والحيوانات
وال
طيور على فكره
ايه الجديد
ثاني احتياج
لنا ونحتاج بالامان
علشان كده في العلاقات الانسانيه ممكن
نستحمل كل حاجه واي حاجه
الا الخيانه
لانها بتاخد مننا الاحساس بالامان الاحساس
بالثقه
الاحساس بالتكامل تاني حاجه محتاجاتها ما
يقدرش نعيش من غيرها في الامان تالت حاجه
بقى ندخل على النجاح دوائر اللي حوالينها
الاصدقاء احنا الانسان كائن
اجتماع فالاصدقاء او المحيط اللي حوالينا
فمن القواعد اللي انا علمت نفسي عليها ان
انا ما اقعدش قاعده مش عجباني على المزاجي
وما
احترام الذات والاحساس بالانجاز والتحقق
احنا دخلنا في المستويات الانسانيه في
الرقي البشري التحقق وهو ده واخر حاجه
التطور والابداع عشان كده النجاح ممتع جدا
جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
جدا كل موت عليها
كل متعه في الحياه دي هتعمل عشان نستمتع
باول ان اولادهم على فكره
ما فيش اعلى من الم الاولاد علشان الاب
يستمتع باولاده لازم يتحمل مسئوليتهم
فبيحس
[موسيقى]
ان تخيلوا كده اولادنا لما بنخلفهم فعلا
للراجل او بالست هم شيلنا قلبنا من جوه
وعملين
نجلمل بقلبنا
اول في النجاح لاعتراف في المسئوليه ما
فيش مشكله احنا نشتر سواء فعل او مفع
مفيش مشكله احنا مش طرف فيه
وبالتالي كل مشكله بنقابلها لازم اسال
نفسي انا مسئوليتي في هذه المشكله قد ايه
ومش شطاره اللي انا كنت ما كنتش بتقولها
ما ليش دعوه انا مش طرف لا
انا حتى لو ما
كنتشرف لاني ما كنتش
لاني ما اتعملتش مع نفسي على ان انا فاعل
تعاملت مع نفسي على اني
تاني قاعده من نجاحنا المحاوله الدائمه
هترميني مش هترمي في وش شفاك هتقفل في وش
الباب هنقولك من الشبا
ك علشان اوصل لهنا شايفين الطياره الخاصه
الجميله دي مش بتاعتي
علشان اوصل لهنا الموضوع ما بيبقاش سهل بس
بيبقى زي ما قلت لكم ممتع زي ما قلت لك في
منطقه ريفيه
ما بتشجعش ان حد يدخل الجامعه قوي دلوقتي
تمام الحمد لله بقينا المدينه المنوره طيب
اخر كلام اخر كلام
قواعد النجاح بقى انا ما عنديش حاجه اسمها
ظروف وحشه
انا طرف في اي حاجه في بعض الناس يقول لك
البنات اهاليهم بيضايقوا عليهم اقري قضيتك
كويس واشرحيها للي حواليك كويس وافهميها
كويس ما تشرخيش وتدبدبي في الارض زي
الاطفال
ساعتها الناس حتى الاهل لانه الاهل
بيخافوا عليك وبيبقوا متخيلين دي طريقه
اللي يعبروا بيها عن حبهم لكن لو اكتشفوا
ان في طرق ثانيه يعبروا بيها بوبو الحوار
هيختلف فضلنا نزعق ونعيط ونقول احنا ضحايا
للظروف وندب في الارض يبقى الاهل عندهم
حقل ان
دي الحاجه التانيه مفيش حاجه اسمها هو كده
لا في شغل ولا في البيت ولا في الشارع ولا
في حاجه اسمها هو كده يعني ايه هو كده هو
كده دي
الفاشل اللي مش عارف يعبر اللي مش عارف
بياخد القرار ده بناء على ايه اللي يقول
لك ما تعمليش هو كده لا اقنعني
مبررات ما عندوش مبررات مزاجه وحش هو كده
انا ما عنديش هو
كده لازم تقول لي هو كده يعني ايه طيب
ما فيش حد احسن منه خالص غرور سمو غرور ما
فيش حد احسن مني
لانه اللي عنده خبره اكتر يا اما ارى اكتر
يا اما اكبر مني
في فانا هبقى زي الفل من الايام الكلام ده
كنت بقوله لنفسي وانا لسه اعداد المدرس
اللي هو بيشرح لي في الفصل مش احسن مني هو
فرق خبره وفرق السن بس فما فيش حد احسن
لو مش عارفه هعرف
ولو مش فاهمه هفهم
وكل حد عنده نقاط ضعف ونقاط قوه
فما ينفعش في الضعف اجلد نفسي
ولا في القوه احس ان انا ملكت الدنيا
بحد بيجيب اخرها
رغم كل الخناقات اللي بيعملوها معنا انا
مؤمنه جدا جدا للمستقبل للعداله وللمساواه
في مصر بشكركم